in Porto prints they Shield their eyes
from the beating Sun but it is not the
Sun that comes for them Gladys holds up
her hands demonstrating what she had to
do to save her life
this but one corner of the capital but
its crowded yard tells of a nation's
turmoil an outpouring of anger
frustration fear almost half Haiti's
population of 11 million people faces
acute hunger we haven't eaten since
yesterday we have nothing to drink we
are suffering even our voice is gone
Louie's wife and a child killed others
made quiet by their loss 96 000 people
displaced by gangs in the capital alone
these people have been displaced not
once but Twice first they fled gang
violence in City du Soleil perhaps the
most dangerous part of Porto press they
fled to a square opposite the airport
and then what happened is the
authorities chased them out so they came
here to the City authorities hoping to
get something what they'd get is a piece
of paper some jostle with their papers
angry neither food nor shelter has been
forthcoming others hand me this single
document which attests that somewhere
they did belong before the gangs struck
they started shooting we had to jump in
the oven there was a lot of us we had to
run in high lay down and wait for the
right time to come out so we could live
then they walked to the capitals Hugo
Chavez Square three thousand displaced
residents from the neighborhood of City
Soleil where the United Nations
assessors 19 000 people face
catastrophic hunger they camped on the
Square's concrete well I don't know when
was the last time I had a proper meal
because we've been living at the camp
sleeping on the ground at night it's
freezing cold when it rained it rained
on us that was until authorities
surrounded the square with a brand new
fence and tossed them out in a matter of
hours I asked where they will sleep
tonight
in the street in the street we have
nowhere to go to sleep the local
administrator says the numbers seeking
Aid here have swelled because locals who
aren't from City of Soleil saw an
opportunity for a handout
a young man's stare provides evidence of
its own in this city we're up to 200
gangs of fighting for territory leaving
displaced citizens with nothing more
than a scrap of paper to call their own
Al Jazeera Porto Prince